who's got your favorite albums of the
year
Kendrick
Ty Dolla signing mustard okay you gotta
disqualify yourself it's not out yet
I know but I'm gonna just be honest is
it coming out this year
Ty Dolla Sign of mustard Kendrick Lamar
uh
what else came out this year uh the
Freddie Gibbs album is great Triple S uh
I love jid's album
Jesus he goes crazy man I'm so proud of
him crazy Curry had a great album this
year Tana talk four from Benny was great
um the Benny album was hard
Finn Staples out when I listen to that
[ __ ] again good time shout out to Vince
for show Vince Staples album is amazing
who are we missing there's been some
good [ __ ] this year though
Simba he's doing his thing yeah he's
killing it Simba was so offended that I
didn't have him in my list for real yeah
I mean it was it was a good project
Simba goes crazy and you're on his first
uh you know you're on yeah
young boy I love it young boy everything
he'd been dropping I [ __ ] with his music
heavy every you've had enough time this
year to listen to everything I'll be
listening to his [ __ ] I [ __ ] with no I
love his music too but I just don't have
time to listen to this motherfucker's
dropped 189 million songs this year he
got out of that Atlantic deal in one
year
he working he's going crazy Dwight's
like [ __ ] you
they just announced the Motown [ __ ] I
was just talking to Dwight what last
week mother said I'm [ __ ] with you
you heard an icy [ __ ] icy [ __ ] yeah that
sounds wild yeah so Rocky put me on his
music a minute ago that's a guy yeah I
do named icy [ __ ] he's from Chicago
that's amazing everything you drop he'll
be he doing the Beats doing everything
in the [ __ ] hard as hell I like lucky
Lucky's dopes yep lucky zombies of
course uh
you already name uh bro but uh [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] a lot West Side you like eat
yeah I like eat shout out I like his
music do you like the minion song
uh I think so it's really like
everything I just be playing the shits
through like the last two three albums
that's why I appreciate about you man
your [ __ ] taste is so vast yeah like
like you're the first person I've ever
heard play little Uzi in my life for
real we were in Boston and I did a show
like a we're in Lawrence uh
Massachusetts with DJ pup dog and
somehow we ended up in a hotel room
afterwards with I think Dre was there
and some strange people as well and uh
and yeah you were playing Uzi on
Soundcloud some strange people yo
another uh Larry June June of course The
Alchemist project hey shout out to
Alchemist man I want to see what's up
with you and Alchemist man how the [ __ ]
both of y'all from L.A yo Dre had his
number I text him from Dre's phone I
said hit me he ain't text me wow I don't
know
what's up Alchemist yeah Larry Jones
been on a tear my brother channeled
trust you heard him he makes like dance
music Funk just a really talented dude
so shout out to channel trust Thundercat
everything he's been dropping worse
um I gotta check out AC TWY that's my
favorite rap name ever yeah check him
out that's gonna [ __ ] with it I thought
that was for sure like icy [ __ ] sounds
like the illest like
if I was like a porn chick
I don't do him like that when you hear
the music I'm telling you okay I'm in
man oh man